this is something that actually came out
of the comments on one of the previous
videos we did about biorefringence and
somebody wanted to know whether double
rainbows were the same kind of effect
so i thought i'd talk about rainbows
so really to explain this i need to do
an experiment i need to show you what a
rainbow actually is so i have here the
sun
and a raindrop
not to scale i have to say
and so hopefully with these two fine
tools we should be able to demonstrate
the physics of rainbows you need to
switch the lights out
okay so if you kind of come down to my
level
okay so if you work your way around
towards the right there's a kind of a
little you can see the little white dot
that sort of reflected off the back of
our giant raindrop there
and as you go around
you'll see that it kind of moves towards
the right so it kind of comes towards
you and then at some point suddenly it
turns colors so you'll see it go blue
green red and then disappear entirely
and the point is you're currently 42
degrees away from the direction that the
light's shining in from when you're at
that
okay so what we've got is we've got the
light coming in and as you can see as it
passes through this surface so it goes
from one medium to another the speed of
light changes which has this effect of
changing the direction that the light's
traveling in
but the amount by which it gets changed
depends on the wavelength of the light
blue light gets bent a little more than
red light so you can see that the blue
light
reaches the back of the drop at a
slightly different point from the red
light
and then when they get reflected back
again and again there's another bit of
refraction when they come out the
raindrop again
and you can see that basically the light
the red light at least in the extreme
rays ends up traveling slightly at a
slightly wider angle than the blue light
that's when you as you were panning
around
the last light you saw was the red light
so you see
just normal reflection pretty much all
the way around to here and then when
you're at this last point where it's
last angle that stuff can actually get
through the drop at all you first see
blue light then you see red light then
you see nothing further out at all of
course that's not what happens with a
rainbow with a rainbow what you have
i'll show you another picture
of course you have lots and lots of
drops which means there's always one at
the right exactly the right angle to
send the red light towards you or to
send the blue light towards you and so
actually what you end up seeing is that
kind of remember this magic angle of
around 42 degrees anything that's around
42 degrees
this angle here between the direction
the sunrise rays are coming from and the
direction you're looking from
you'll end up seeing either red light or
a little bit further out you'll see blue
light that actually means that rainbows
actually are
round right there's actually there's a
circle of points that are 42 degrees
away from from this line to the sun
but what actually happens is that half
of that circle is typically below the
horizon so that you see like half a
circle of the of the light and so you'll
end up just seeing the classic kind of
rainbow semi-circle if you have to be at
this magic 42 degree angle
how come i can see a rainbow and johnny
smith five miles away can see a rainbow
because he's looking at different set of
raindrops so he's still looking 42
degrees away from the sun but from from
where he's standing he sees a completely
different set of raindrops that are all
doing exactly the same thing back
towards you so when i see a rambo at my
house and you see a rambo over at your
house we're actually seeing two
different rainbows you're seeing a
different set of raindrops that are
causing the the effect i mean obviously
it's the same sun that's causing the
effect and it's the same physics but
it's a different set of raindrops
reflecting it all back to you and the
other thing you noticed is that when you
went beyond so when you were looking
kind of closer to the sun or sort of
closer to straight backwards and
forwards
um so kind of when you're looking at
light just reflected off the back of the
raindrop you saw basically white light
and it's only when you get to these
these extreme angles that you actually
see the red and the blue light and of
course that's why if you look at a
picture of a rainbow you'll always see
that inside the rainbow is always
brighter than outside the rainbow
because inside the rainbow you're seeing
just mostly that whitish light being
reflected back it's the sum of all the
different colors being reflected back to
you so you see it as white light then
you reach this edge of it where you're
just about seeing just those last few
colors and then when you go to to wider
angles still you see nothing at all and
that's why the outside of the rainbow
appears darker than the inside of the
rainbow
at the start
i thought you were holding out the
promise of something about double
rainbows double rainbows we can do too
so double rainbows
also again classically understood going
back at least as far as so descartes did
this experiment again in the 17th
century lots of people had a go at this
and what they realized is so if we go
back to our original picture for just a
second
so what was happening here is the light
comes in gets refracted reflected once
off the back of the raindrop comes back
out refracted again
in a double rainbow what happens is the
light takes a slightly different path
another picture you can have the light
coming in gets refracted gets reflected
once reflected twice
and then comes back out again and comes
out at a different angle from if it had
just undergone a single reflection at
the back this is another way of making a
rainbow at a different angle so the
first way still works you can have
things for light coming in and getting
reflected once and that'll give us a
rainbow at one angle or it can go in get
reflected twice and then we end up with
a rainbow at two angles so you end up
with a picture like this so we've still
got the first rainbow here where the
light's coming in getting reflected back
to us just once off the back of the
raindrop
and so we see the the colors spread blue
to red but there's a second way that it
can happen that it can actually bounce
twice around the raindrop and take this
rather more complicated path and what
you can see is that actually the rainbow
ends up being reversed because of that
second reflection uh where the red light
was originally on the outside if you
look you at a second rainbow you'll see
that actually the color is inverted that
the the original rainbow the inner
rainbow goes from blue to red the second
rainbow goes from red to blue
and in fact all the effects are reversed
so as we were talking about before you
see a brighter light down here then you
see a normal rainbow for the other
rainbow everything's reversed so you see
the second rainbow and then you see
brighter light further away and so the
famously you see this thing called
alexander's band which is the dark
region in between where there's no white
light gets reflected at all because in
the first rainbow it's all ending up
down here and from the second rainbow
it's all ending up there it seems to me
we should see a double rainbow every
time and yet we only occasionally see a
double rainbow
it really is because that so what
happens is that in the raindrop most of
the light just goes straight through
only a little bit of it gets reflected
and so actually it's a very inefficient
process most of the light just travels
straight through the raindrop a little
bit of it gets reflected of course if
you want to reflect it twice that means
a little bit gets reflected then only a
little bit of the little bit gets
reflected and so the second rainbow is
always much fainter than the first so it
is actually always there and in fact
very occasionally you can even see a
third rainbow which is even fainter
still so these other rainbows are always
still there but they're always much
fainter so if you can only just see the
primary rainbow you're not going to see
the secondary rainbow at all and it's
always when you have a really stonkingly
bright primary rainbow that you end up
seeing the secondary one people often
ask this question
you know don't you lose the magic of
something by actually understanding it
you know by actually understanding where
a rainbow comes from isn't it not
beautiful anymore because suddenly
you've explained it and it's all very
simple and trivial
and of course it doesn't right i mean
you know i understand the physics of
rainbows but i can still go out and look
at one and say wow that's pretty so it
really did you know it doesn't have that
negative effect at all it's just it just
adds to the experience of seeing a
rainbow that not only does it look
beautiful but you actually understand
why it looks beautiful too